i'm not gonna eat the spinal cord you
want to talk about it maybe would you
eat it yeah i feel like these are the
parameters of like anything in here i
have to eat oh oh you're eating it tacos
[Music]
[Music]
what's up guys we're back for another
great episode of tacos contodo we're
going to eat some amazing birya right
here in the heart of beautiful boyle
heights the epicenter of flavor and good
stuff
if you remember from season one we are
on olympic the same street as mariscos
jalisco birella unica but we're at a
very special spot
busy al
big shout out to l.a taco thank you for
the recommendation
so we got none other than the gene
waring joke slangin the man the myth the
legend one of my favorites mr mark maron
will be here having beeria and when i
talked to him at the parking lot at the
comedy store he said i only do the show
if
you take me to the best spot the best
spot happens to be
right here in the alleyway of an
industrial laundromat you said the best
bro look at the font mark
[Music]
you notice how everyone just rolls up
their windows as soon as they get to me
[Music]
mark what's up buddy what's up man
thanks for coming out here i'm good man
where am i you said you would only do
the spot if it was only like the best
food yeah it just happens to be in a
driveway next to an industrial laundry
mat for denim okay all right is that
really that's an industrial laundromat
for denim they start at 8am and they
usually sell out by noon really are we
too late no no this is great this is the
most romantic thing i've ever done it's
like i closed down the restaurant just
for you bro oh thanks yeah i mean i
appreciate it that's very nice i'm gonna
show you a gift or anything no no you're
here that's the gift dude
i
suggest that we go with the number one
yeah okay it's all goat yeah it's all
goat meat okay so it's a little stringy
a little uh man you're really selling
this stringy that's it that's always
something you want to hear about food
yes
it doesn't matter
[Applause]
i like cookies well yeah we're gonna
we'll recognize real don't let me hang
it now we're on camera there it is
my name is
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
limes cilantro onions
yeah a little bit of everything
beautiful thank you
all right gracias you go in there yeah
just grab it
oh see it's like rolling the blunt you
gotta you gotta get one side in wrap it
and then it doesn't drip on the bottom
got it
i just thought there was bones in there
good that's hot yeah and good
wow
this is good man
i told you nothing but the best there's
some spinal cord a little spinal cord a
little bit of everything again thank you
for doing this i'm such a big fan and
and
i am a fan of yours too my friend that's
insane i'm glad that cameras are rolling
on that when i first met you yeah
is this a mark as an [ __ ] story i
love these stories i i meet you at the
store i'm a door guy i'm parking cars
yeah i kept to myself for a long time
yeah i would just say hi here you go
mark i'll get you right at out mark now
the first time you see me on stage
is one of those some comics running late
yeah so i'm up there giving it my all
for my hot five minutes till somebody
shows up yeah and i'm up there
giving it to the stool i'm like humping
the stool i mean i'm i'm
i'm in rem state like thrust mode yeah
yeah yeah and then i look over to jeff
scott wrestling piece jeff scott i look
over to him i'm like who am i bringing
up
mark marion i said oh wow you know this
guy tv show our special one of the best
podcasts mark marion place goes nuts and
as a comic you kind of linger in the
room a little actually see what mark has
to say
and you sit on the stool and you go
one day
the stool is gonna [ __ ] back
yeah yeah and then as you're doing your
set i remember it wobbled he's like see
yeah he's like i'm not the guy i i
wasn't up here doing that to you kind of
thing the place is going nuts right yeah
the stool [ __ ] yeah yeah so i
remember i'm like in the hallway and you
you know kind of walk off i'm like hey
my heart probably fishing for a
compliment i wouldn't put it past myself
and then you looked at me like i was as
civil as i could have been up there i'm
like yeah
and that was it but now
take that to
most recently my phone blows up yeah hey
mark is talking about you yeah i said oh
[ __ ] does he still remember the still
[ __ ] bit
yeah i was at the store the other night
and i followed jesus trejo and he just
like these are young guys and trejo just
[ __ ] killed to hear those kind words
coming from you that's insane i i can't
tell you how much i appreciate that the
reason i said that about you is like it
was one of those things i mean i've been
doing this a long enough time
and i've known guys in my generation
but the stool was [ __ ] up it was more
about the storm yeah
yeah yeah but you just happened to [ __ ]
this door which i think you got rid of
which is good
yeah i got rid of it
i closed with that now now i'm kidding
i will never do that we don't [ __ ] the
stool oh but like what happened when i
was backstage and you were going on
before me in the main room it's just
like all of a sudden you just hear like
someone in the pocket you know you hear
somebody like has done the work
and you hear somebody like that's
killing and he's on top of it is it you
know in control of his game and i heard
it was and i was listening i'm like holy
[ __ ] that guy's he's he's here now he's
a guy i'm not gonna eat the spinal cord
why is that
you want to talk about it maybe would
you eat it yeah i feel like these are
the parameters of like anything in here
i have to eat oh oh you're eating it
mark
fine it's fine
it's fine such a hard thing to stand out
right it's like even when you look at a
place like this it's like how do they
find success how do they stand out what
are the things that you think helped you
kind of stand out for years like i don't
think anyone knew what to do with me and
they would try to put me in a box like
oh he's the cranky guy the angry guy but
i don't think i was that palatable i
think i was really angry and really
insecure and really afraid so i didn't
really sell tickets until after the
podcast i was already in my 40s dude wow
so nothing's really changed other than
i'm walking into rooms where everybody
knows who i am
and they're supportive and they're
excited to see me
but that doesn't mean i won't make it
difficult yeah to like me i know that
i'm still a discoverable guy like i know
most people still don't know me which is
good
you know so there's always room for
people to show up yeah but we'll see
what happens the world is ending so it's
all up in the air
and true marc maron fashion there it is
now i'm just eating the spinal cord i
don't care hell yeah dude
wow so hector works here yeah his
brother owns this spot and this is a
denim
uh company they stonewash them stone
here's something right here for people
who don't want to break in their own
pants yeah yeah
that's one of my like my favorite uh
bits in that special that i had it's
like
like trying to explain to your immigrant
father that you bought jeans that
already were pre-ripped yeah yeah he's
like no one's going to believe that your
pants rip telling jokes right like no
it's a thing i used to do a joke about
people who uh
who bought like used you know like work
shirts with names on them and the joke
was like yeah it probably belonged to
someone who had a job
it's good that it feels so safe in here
i'm i'm oh for sure it's it's it's up to
cal osha oh yeah sure yeah
hector is
[Applause]
yeah the tanks and this is all the stone
the rocks but this is already too smooth
to use so they can't use it it's like
hummus it's like that volcano's tube
yeah they bring it in from mexico oh
yeah yeah is it legal yeah of course
this is the legal rock you can ship by
the way i know any other kind of rock no
way no take this right yeah take it look
finished pants yeah so look these are
the different versions of the of the
pants right here
huh what do you think well yeah i'm a
jeans guy aren't you yeah there's a
party that's sort of like are we
shopping
yeah
that's why i was so excited to bring you
in here is there a dressing room
somewhere just go for it see these kind
of like rubber things yeah they put them
in there and this puffs out yeah and
then they toss them no they send them by
hand in question
[Music]
[Music]
you never know when you have an amazing
food experience mark marion starts off
in a garage yeah i mean yeah now you're
in a different place now there's a
studio with lights and an engineer in
there and this and that so if this place
was like in a in a food court of sorts
or like a a food hall what is gained
what is lost well ultimately what
happens is people that knew about this
place before will say like ah i used to
go when it was just in a garage and it
was better even if it wasn't better the
experience meant something to them
because it was unique to them but i
think a food hall could only i think
most of the time will
will give them a better
working environment we'll give them an
opportunity to have more dishes if they
want right to expand the efficiency yeah
and also probably bring more people in
now the risk is that you know to
accommodate the demand the heart might
not be as connected so the food might
suffer they make it the same way but if
your heart's not in it
it tastes different do you feel that
that's what happens now to this in this
day and age like like comedy specials or
as somebody like is coming up they're
developing this thing and then
the powers to be start diluting the the
thing well yeah because there's so much
demand for content i've done [ __ ] where
i wasn't ready for it and i've seen it
and i know what it looks like you know
there's so much content there's less to
lose that's the weird thing it's like
it's similar in a way i guess to the
food hall thing is that uh
it does get diluted but less people
know about it so i could get a special
on whatever the hell it is remember that
joke i used to do clomper
that you know
do you get clumper what is that i don't
even know what they are you get the
opportunity but what does it really mean
no one can see it there's something
respectable about somebody that says hey
i cook this much and i'm out at noon
yeah it's almost like a comic the
artist's integrity of it where you're
like hey i'm i have to turn down these
things because i know that the
bj aka the joke is not cooked all the
way so i'm gonna service these
opportunities and the rest i'm out sure
it takes a lot of guts to say no get
that thing you got a little thing it's
gone
um
[Applause]
people aren't going to notice you until
your whole thing anyway like something
happens it's some sort of magic and
that's what i was telling you about when
i kind of heard it when i was backstage
and you were on i was like oh man this
guy's arrived he's a full-on
comic now
is that there's different points of that
you know what i mean where like you
think you got it because it's you
but people aren't quite seeing it but
eventually if you're lucky people get it
because of the podcast where i could
engage everything that i am
people got to know me
right and they're like i get it
and you can't make that happen you don't
know when it's going to happen but if
you're lucky it happens if you work see
the oil that's gonna be good
it's just it's just mexican cookies yeah
it's like redundant if you say greasy
i didn't mean that
oh oh there's stuff in them yes
you know what that is
sugar more sugar more sugar yeah
sugar so on your podcast often time the
the tone is the world is ending kind of
things like i do stay hopeful as mark
marin the standard comedian it's really
something i think about a lot now
because
it's hard to it's hard to decide
you know what our responsibility is
as comics and also as entertainers you
know i don't know that i'm hopeful
but i do know that
i can
see reality as i see it and share that
in a funny way yeah and i think it
provides some relief i mean i'm opening
my show
my standup right now with uh
i don't want to be negative but i don't
think anything's ever going to get
better ever again
that's my opening line but that's what
now i'm burning it on your show what
that's what everyone's thinking and
feeling right now so yeah and the
laughter is cathartic and weird so i'm
going for the cathartic and weird but i
wouldn't say i have hope but i'm trying
to remain
realistic and honest about what's
happening
and
uh in the present that's all i can
really do hey if you've got kids i'm
sorry not gonna be easy for them and if
you don't have kids
eat a cookie
well mark thank you so much for taking
time on your saturday to come out here
and have some music yeah and um i hope
you loved it it's great good food nice
to see you big fan thanks man
crazy i mean what do you what do you say
to that mark mayor ladies and gentlemen
tacos contodo we'll see you next one
[Music]
hello my name is jesus draco i'm the
host of tacos contolo and don't forget
to like and subscribe you can watch more
right here hurry watch another episode
before your boss comes in and you get
fired for real this time